on peut reprocher à route c'est d'avoir
cessé de faire de la science et de la
médecine sada politique rcsa c'est qu'en
fait il a politisé
un sujet qui devrait rester un sujet un
sujet scientifique
il a abandonné les principes
fondamentaux de la médecine au moment où
on en avait le plus besoin pour essayer
de montrer qu'il avait raison lancés çà
fondamentalement c'est qu'il a
transformé il ya chu de marseille en
centre mondial du lobbying de la
chloroquine encore à fait logique bien
dire à l'instant non mais c'est bien oui
t'as tony cherche qui marche qui marche
pas non les ja cherche à montrer coûte
que coûte que la chloroquine ça marche
point final c'est systématiquement une
déconstruction de toute étude qui du
contraire c'est on passe sous silence un
certain nombre d'autres études qui
montrent certains dangers du traitement
mais en avoir des études complètement
bidon ou comme celle du professeur
période avec fait un putsch magnificat
et au regard des professeurs peron super
l'étude a été retirée comme 7 27
quelques jours après on n'a pas parlé
des os et cacher la vérité aux gens
pressés de faire croire que la
chloroquine ça marche voilà une étude
qui montrait que les plus rock in
semblait un peu dangereuse aw a fait un
petit papier en réponse en disant non ne
c'est pas vrai c'est pas dangereux et
pour faire ça il cite une troisième
étude dans l'étude dit il prend la
chloroquine pas dangereuse c'est le
résultat de notre étude pourrait dire
très bien mais quand vous premier
l'étude ce qui est citée par as où il ya
une suite ses marques et virgule par
contrat si vous mettez à l'antibiotique
donc c'est fait le protocole raoult
c'est très dangereux ça augmente la
mortalité c'est quand même très bizarre
d'avoir sous le nez une étude qui dit
protocole est dangereux pour faire
croire aux gens que votre hôte open
n'est pas dangereux merci ça la méthode
raoult en fait mais ça se comprend très
bien parce que c'est plus de la science
il n'y a pas de débat scientifique comme
virelaude 90% des scientifiques voit
très bien que ça ne marche pas avec un
gros problème méthodologique
mais évidemment il ya un problème aussi
médiatique essaie de faire croire que
désire garder ça divise les sont pas
très divisé les scientifiques à
comprendre quelqu'un qui a un doctorat
en théologie en biochimie qui connait la
science il voit très bien qui après un
gros problème évidemment c'est pareil à
l'étranger lire tous les chasseurs de
fausses sciences ont descendu ces
travaux là
[Musique]